Imagine, um, a teenager who just constantly screams at their parents.
Right.
Like, a flat-out refuses to do homework,
slams doors so hard the pictures actually fall off the wall.
Yeah, we've all seen that or at least heard about it.
Right.
But then imagine a completely different teenager.
This one, uh, sneaks out at night and literally sets the neighbor's car on fire.
Which is a massive, massive escalation.
Exactly, but society tends to look at both of them and just, you know,
you use the exact same umbrella label, we just say they're both problem children.
Right, they get put in the same box.
But clinically speaking, one of them might just be going through this really intense,
frustrating phase of development, but the other one,
they're displaying a documented, undeniable precursor to adult psychopathy.
Which is a huge distinction.
It's massive.
Yeah.
But, you know, to the untrained eye or even just to a frustrated parent or a teacher,
all of it just looks like bad behavior.
We see acting out, we see aggression and we just want to label it all as the same thing.
But the clinical dividing lines between these behaviors,
they are incredibly sharp, assuming you actually know where to look.
Which brings us to our mission for today.
So welcome to the deep dive, everyone.
We are looking at a really compelling stack of clinical study notes today
and they map out the whole spectrum of disruptive impulse control and conduct disorders.
It's fascinating stuff.
It really is.
And for those of you listening, this matters because, I mean, we encounter difficult,
even destructive behavior all the time, right?
In our families, in public spaces, on the news.
Absolutely.
So our goal today is to trace the spine of these conditions.
We want to discover the exact threshold where, you know,
a frustrating personality trait morphs into a diagnosable psychiatric condition
and how one severe disorder kind of bleeds into the next.
Yeah, it's essentially a progression of severity.
We are looking at the escalating mechanisms of how
human beings break rules, push boundaries, and ultimately how they lose control.
And honestly, the most helpful way to understand this
isn't by just, like, memorizing a bulleted list of symptoms.
It's by looking at the underlying why.
Like, what is actually driving the defiance?
Is it a calculated choice or is it a biological misfire?
Okay, let's unpack this from the very bottom of the ladder.
We are starting at the baseline of the severity progression
with something called oppositional defiant disorder, or ODD.
Right, the classic ODD.
Yeah, and in the medical world where, you know,
everything needs a specific code for insurance billing and universal tracking,
you'll see this filed under F91.3.
Got to have the codes.
Always.
But beyond the clinical code, the notes paint a picture of a very specific,
sustained attitude problem.
We're talking about a pattern of angry, irritable moods,
highly argumentative behavior, and vindictiveness that lasts for at least six months.
And that timeframe is critical.
I mean, everyone is a bad week, right?
A teenager failing a math test and acting out for a few days,
that does not mean they have a psychiatric disorder.
Obviously not.
Yeah.
But a six-month sustained pattern.
That indicates a behavioral loop that the individual just cannot break out of on their own.
And furthermore, this behavior is almost exclusively relational.
Meaning what, exactly?
Meaning it is aimed directly at authority figures.
Parents, teachers, coaches, people trying to tell them what to do.
But wait, how do we know this isn't just a kid pushing boundaries?
I mean, toddlers go through the terrible twos, right?
Oh, for sure.
And teenagers are practically biologically programmed to rebel.
So where's the actual line between just normal pushy independence
and a diagnosable disorder like ODD?
Well, the separator is actually quite black and white in the clinical literature.
Oppositional Defined Disorder does not involve serious violations of others' rights.
That is the hard boundary line.
Meaning they aren't crossing into actual criminality or like physical abuse?
They are not.
ODD is strictly about defiance and irritability.
So a teenager with ODD might scream in your face, refuse to do any of their chores,
and maliciously spread a rumor about you because they are feeling vindictive.
Wow, sounds exhausting.
It is deeply unpleasant to be around.
But they are not destroying the physical house.
They aren't physically harming the family pet.
They aren't stealing cars.
They are pushing relational boundaries to the absolute breaking point,
but they are not violating fundamental human rights.
Got it.
So it's an attitude problem cranked up to a clinical extreme,
but the harm is mostly emotional and relational,
which actually brings me to the treatment side of things.
Okay, yeah.
Because the source notes state that the first line defense for ODD
is parent management training,
and specifically something called parent-child interaction therapy.
Yes, PCIT.
But I have to push back on this a little bit.
If the child is the one throwing the six-month tantrum,
and they clearly have the biological or behavioral issue,
why on earth is the parent the one going to therapy?
I mean, that just sounds like we're blaming the parents.
I completely understand why it sounds that way.
I really do.
But it has absolutely nothing to do with blame.
It comes down to the mechanics of the disorder itself.
Yeah.
ODD requires a dynamic.
Defiance cannot exist in a vacuum, right?
Right.
It requires an authority figure to defy.
Oh, that makes sense.
Right.
If you just put an eight-year-old with ODD into a room with a therapist,
do like talk about their feelings,
you aren't addressing the actual mechanism of the disorder.
Because the parent isn't there.
Exactly.
The mechanism is the feedback loop between the child and the parent.
So you really have to treat the whole ecosystem,
not just the individual kid.
Precisely.
Let's look at how parent-child interaction therapy,
or PCIT, actually works in practice.
Because it's pretty fascinating.
Yeah.
How does it work?
Well, the therapist doesn't just sit on a couch
and ask the parent how their week went.
The parent and child are put into a playroom together.
Okay.
The therapist sits behind a one-way mirror,
and the parent actually wears an earpiece.
Wait, really?
Like a producer in a news anchor's ear?
Very much like that, yeah.
The therapist coaches the parent in real time.
When the child starts to act out,
the therapist will tell the parent exactly what to do
in that exact moment.
That is wild.
They'll say, turn your back and ignore this specific whining,
or the moment he shares that block, praise him warmly.
You see, the child's brain has learned that negative, defiant behavior
gets this high-intensity reaction from the parent.
Pray, like yelling back or paying a lot of attention to them.
Exactly.
PCIT mechanically rewires that dynamic.
Right.
By changing the parent's half of the interaction,
you basically starve the defiant behavior of the reaction it craves.
So the kid stops getting the payoff?
Exactly.
And you force the child's brain to find new, positive ways
to engage to get that attention.
That is incredibly practical.
You aren't just giving vague advice,
like telling the parent to just be firmer.
You are live coaching a brand new neural pathway for both of them.
Exactly.
But obviously, this intervention doesn't always work,
or perhaps the underlying issue is just more severe from the very start.
So what happens when that boundary of others' rights is finally crossed?
If ODD is just an argument, what do we call it
when the behavior becomes genuinely destructive?
That is when we cross the clinical threshold into conduct disorder.
Okay, conduct disorder.
Yes.
The entire profile of the patient shifts here.
We move away from mere defiance,
and we move into actions that actively hurt, take, and destroy.
Yeah.
The symptom list in the notes for conduct disorder is heavy.
It's defined as a repetitive pattern
that violates the basic rights of others or major age-appropriate societal norms.
It's a major escalation.
We are looking at physical aggression toward people or animals,
destruction of property, deceitfulness, theft,
and serious rule violations like chronic truancy or running away.
Notice the shift there.
We've moved from shouting at a teacher
to potentially setting the teacher's property on fire
or physically assaulting a classmate.
It's much darker.
It is.
Conduct disorder causes tangible, often physical harm
to the world around the individual.
It is a fundamental empathy deficit.
Here is where it gets really interesting for me.
The sources outline a direct timeline connecting
this specific childhood behavior to adult personality disorders.
Conduct disorder isn't just an isolated phase.
It's a bridge.
It is a very specific medically required bridge.
The developmental pathway here is stark.
According to the clinical criteria,
having conduct disorder before the age of 15
is the required developmental precursor
for diagnosing antisocial personality disorder at age 18.
Okay, let's make sure you, the listener, caught that.
You literally cannot be diagnosed with antisocial personality disorder,
which is what pop culture often refers to as psychopathy
or sociopathy as an adult,
unless there is a documented history of conduct disorder in your childhood.
Correct.
Because antisocial personality disorder
doesn't just spontaneously generate on someone's 18th birthday.
Right, you don't just wake up one day like that.
No, the foundation for that profound disregard for the rights of others
is lay down, practiced, and cemented during childhood and adolescence.
But why the strict age distinction?
Why not just call an incredibly violent 10-year-old
a psychopath and be done with it?
Well, primarily because a child's brain is still highly plastic.
Meaning it can change.
Yes, the frontal lobe is still actively developing.
Society and the medical community in general
are very hesitant ethically and clinically
to brand a child with a permanent personality disorder label
when there is still a window for structural change.
That makes total sense.
So conduct disorder is essentially the warning flare.
It says, the cement is still wet,
but it is drying in a very, very dangerous shape.
If the behavior persists past age 18,
when personality traits become largely crystallized,
then the diagnosis shifts to antisocial personality disorder.
Wow, that makes the stakes of early intervention incredibly high.
You are literally racing against the clock of brain development.
You really are.
So far, we've traced a line from the relational defiance of ODD
to the calculated rights-violating actions of conduct disorder.
But the notes then take us in a completely different direction.
They do.
We shift from calculated aggression to aggression
that lacks any premeditation at all.
We are moving from the planned attack to the sudden eruption.
And this brings us to intermittent explosive disorder, or IED.
The defining feature here isn't a lack of empathy, like we saw before.
And it isn't a calculated plan to steal or destroy.
It is defined by recurrent, impulsive, aggressive outbursts.
I want to try to visualize the difference between these two
because from the outside looking in,
I imagine they look totally identical.
Oh, they definitely can.
Like, if I'm sitting in a restaurant
and a guy suddenly shatters a glass and flips a table,
I'm just seeing violence, right?
But the clinical mechanism is different.
Very different.
So if conduct disorder is, say,
a calculated premeditated bank heist
where violence is just a tool to get the money,
would IED be more like a guy who flips his table
just because the waiter brought him cold coffee?
That is a highly effective way to separate the two.
It perfectly highlights the clinical trap of misdiagnosis, actually.
How so?
Well, an untrained observer just sees a shattered glass, right?
And they assign the exact same malicious intent to both people.
But the keyword for IED is impulsive.
The aggression in IED is grossly out of proportion
to whatever provoked it.
So the cold coffee triggers a literal nuclear meltdown?
Yes, exactly.
For a person with conduct disorder, aggression is a tool.
It's used to assert dominance or get revenge
or acquire property.
It is goal-directed.
But for IED?
For a person with intermittent explosive disorder,
the aggression is not a tool at all.
It's an overload of the central nervous system.
It's a sudden, reactive spark.
So there's no plan?
None.
They aren't trying to achieve anything by flipping the table.
They have simply failed to contain an internal neurological misfire.
That completely explains the dramatic shift in treatment we see in the notes.
With ODD, we treated the parent-child relationship.
But the notes state the first line treatment for IED
is cognitive behavioral therapy, or CBT.
Which totally makes sense.
You can't train a parent or a spouse to prevent a misfire
that happens entirely inside someone else's brain.
Exactly.
You have to give the individual themselves the tools
to manage their own internal warning system.
And the mechanism of how CBT actually does this for IED patients is remarkable.
I've heard of CBT.
It's pretty common, right?
Very common.
It's based on the cognitive triangle.
That's the constant interaction between your thoughts,
your feelings, and your behaviors.
So what is a CBT session for someone with IED actually look like?
How do you stop a nuclear meltdown with talk therapy?
Well, you don't just talk.
You train the brain to slow down time.
Oh, wow.
See, in an IED patient, the microsecond between the trigger...
So the cold coffee and the reaction flipping the table is almost non-existent.
It's instant.
Basically, yeah.
The amygdala, which is the fear and anger center of the brain,
completely hijacks the system before the frontal lobe.
The logical part of the brain even knows what's happening.
Oh, so the logic center is literally lagging behind.
Precisely.
So CBT teaches the patient to identify the somatic markers,
which are the physical warning signs in their own body,
before the explosion actually happens.
Like realizing your heart rate just spiked or your fists are clenching
before you've even fully processed while you're mad.
Exactly that.
The therapist helps the patient recognize that physical spike.
And once they can recognize it,
they introduce a wedge, a physical or cognitive grounding technique.
A wedge.
Like what?
It might be a specific breathing pattern they practice
or a mental checklist they run through.
This wedge forces a delay.
Ah, I suck.
It buys the frontal lobe those crucial seconds it needs to catch up,
analyze the situation, and realize,
hey, this is just cold coffee.
This is not a life-threatening emergency.
You're essentially teaching them how to manually override
their own sympathetic nervous system.
That's incredible.
It's very powerful when it works.
So with conduct disorder,
the aggression is projected outward to take or destroy.
But IED introduces us to this concept
of internal impulsive drives.
The aggression is a failure to contain an internal reaction.
Yes.
And our sources follow this exact thread
to look at two other impulse control disorders
that operate entirely on internal logic.
And these next two are heavily featured in movies and television,
but their actual clinical mechanics
are widely misunderstood by the general public.
Yeah, I feel like I've seen these a million times on TV.
Oh, definitely.
We are talking about kleptomania and pyromania.
Let's lay out the strict clinical definitions first.
So kleptomania is the irresistible urge
to steal objects that are not needed
for personal use or for their monetary value.
Right.
And pyromania is defined as fire setting
specifically for tension relief.
What really stands out to me here
is the total lack of external logic.
How so?
I mean, why would someone risk their freedom,
risk a literal prison sentence,
to steal a pack of gum they don't even want,
or burn down an empty shed in the middle of nowhere?
What's fascinating here is that to understand this,
we have to look at the shared core mechanism
driving both of these disorders.
Okay.
The text explicitly states that these behaviors
are purely about relieving internal tension.
They have absolutely nothing to do with personal gain.
So a kleptomaniac isn't stealing a Rolex to pawn it
and pay off a debt?
No.
If they are stealing a Rolex to pawn it,
that is just ordinary criminal theft.
A kleptomaniac is far more likely to steal
like a handful of paper clips
or a cheap plastic toy from a diner.
It's just junk, basically.
Exactly.
The value of the object is totally irrelevant.
The disorder is rooted in an unbearable buildup
of psychological and physical tension.
Can you walk me through
what that actually feels like for the patient?
Because for someone who doesn't have this impulse,
it's really hard to grasp why you wouldn't just, you know,
not steal the paper clips.
Think about it like this.
Imagine the physical sensation of needing to sneeze.
Okay, yeah.
You feel that tickle in your nose,
the pressure builds up in your head,
your eyes start to water.
If you try to hold it in,
the pressure becomes the only thing you can focus on, right?
It consumes your entire physical being.
It's all you can think about.
Right.
For someone with pyromania or kleptomania,
they experience a psychological equivalent
to that exact buildup.
The anxiety and tension rise to a crushing level.
The act of stealing
or the act of setting the fire is the sneeze.
Wow, it's the release valve?
It is an immediate chemical neurological release.
The moment the act is committed, the tension drops.
They experience a wave of profound relief,
sometimes even euphoria.
But then what?
Well, it's followed very closely by intense guilt or shame
once the logical brain catches up
and realizes what they've just done.
And this total lack of gain is the clinical separator.
It's what makes these actions diagnosable psychiatric disorders
rather than just, you know, typical criminal behavior.
It fundamentally changes the intent.
If someone burns down a failing business warehouse
to collect the insurance money, that is arson.
Right.
It is goal directed, it's calculated,
and it's done for financial gain.
But if they burn down an abandoned dumpster
behind a grocery store,
because the urge to see the flames
was literally the only way to stop
a suffocating internal panic attack,
that is pyromania.
Exactly.
The outward action is identical.
Something is on fire.
But the internal why dictates
whether we are looking at a calculated criminal strategy
or a severe impulse control disorder.
That's a huge difference.
It is.
And this goes back to our overarching theme today.
You cannot diagnose behavior based solely on the aftermath.
It really is an incredible spectrum
when you laid out functionally like that.
We started this deep dive
looking for the spine of these disorders,
trying to find exactly where one ends and the next begins.
Yeah.
We moved from oppositional defiant disorder,
where the behavior is intensely confrontational
and authority driven,
but still steps short of violating fundamental human rights.
Then we crossed that critical threshold
into conduct disorder.
That is where basic rights are violated,
bringing calculated aggression,
destruction, and deceit into the picture.
Right.
And we mapped how that serves
as the concrete developmental precursor
to adult antisocial personality disorder.
And then from there,
we pivoted away from calculated actions entirely,
exploring the sudden disproportionate
and non-goal directed reactions
of intermittent explosive disorder.
The table flippers.
Yeah, exactly.
We looked at how the brain's alarm system
misfires over something as small as cold coffee
and how cognitive behavioral therapy
can teach a patient to manually override that system.
Finally, we explored the internal pressure cookers
of kleptomania and pyromania.
We saw how the unbearable buildup of internal tension
drives behavior that defies all external logic,
driven entirely by the desperate need
for psychological relief
rather than personal gain.
It's a progression that really forces us
to look past our initial judgments.
Think about how society
usually evaluates these actions, right?
Stealing, destruction, explosions of anger.
Though we judge them harshly.
We almost exclusively view them
through a moral or a criminal lens.
We judge the person based entirely
on the mess they left behind.
But viewing these actions
through this clinical lens of internal tension relief
or relational feedback loops
or developmental precursors,
it completely shifts the paradigm.
It changes the entire conversation.
It moves us away from simply asking,
how do we punish this?
To asking, what is the structural failure here
and what is the precise clinical intervention
required to fix it?
Which is a much more hopeful,
actionable way to look at the human brain.
So I want to leave you with this final thought
as we wrap up today.
The next time you see a news story
about an inexplicable disproportionate
outburst in a public place
or a bizarre theft
where the person seemingly had no reason
to take the item,
catch yourself before you jump
to a moral conclusion.
Good advice.
Ask yourself,
are you looking at a calculated crime
or are you looking at a pressure cooker
that just lacked the right clinical release valve?
Human behavior doesn't show up
on a neat and tidy x-ray.
To really understand
why people do the things they do,
you have to be willing
to navigate the murky waters
of their internal world.